demain à 10h30 monsieur valéry giscard
d'estaing prendra solennellement ses
fonctions en s'installant l'elysée puis
il remontera les champs elysées
terminant le parcours à pied à partir de
10h 5 en direct sur notre antenne
il ya encore eu des combats aujourd'hui
sur le front israélo syriens tandis que
monsieur kissinger faisait la navette
entre jérusalem et damas on dit toujours
qu'un accord est imminent
suite de notre enquête sur la crise de
confiance qui oppose le président nixon
aux citoyens américains après l' affaire
du watergate ce soir l'impassibilité de
richard nixon
une grande première médicale filmé en
exclusivité des spécialistes français
annoncent qu'ils ont pu faire entendre
des sujets condamné à la surdité depuis
la naissance
regardez bien c'est le début du grand
prix de monaco
forte heureusement ces images
spectaculaires n'ont pas fait de victime
mais sur 22 voitures au départ il n'y en
avait plus que 9 à l'arrivée le grand
vainqueur est le suédois ronnie peterson
sur lotus devant une tyrrell puis une
shade of pilotée par le français jean
paul charié est quatrième une ferrat
nous enverrons les images de ce grand
prix dans ce port d'illange bien entendu
et vous reverrez aussi l'arrivée du
tiercé 4,17 et 1 et celle de la course
cycliste bordeaux paris qu aurait dû
remporter le belge van springel mais il
a été déclassé pour erreur de parcours
c'est donc le français delépine qui est
le vainqueur officiel n'est la moselle
messieurs bonsoir c'est donc demain
matin que monsieur valéry giscard
d'estaing prendra effectivement ses
fonctions de président de la république
demain aussi que l'on connaîtra le nom
de son premier ministre
et après demain la liste complète de son
gouvernement
l'histoire du septennat de valéry
giscard d'estaing commence effectivement
dob et c'est son installation officielle
à l'elysée suivi de son premier contact
avec la foule parisienne qui serviront
de prologue à cette histoire
vous savez que nouveau président a
quelque peu bousculé le protocole pour
qu'ils soient moins solennel et moins
guindé jacques hébert a répété pour vous
cette matinée du président placée sous
le signe de la simplicité vestimentaire
d'un contact plus direct avec la foule
et d'une musique personnalisés le chant
du départ
demain matin 10h le président valéry
giscard d'estaing qui a décidé
d'abandonner la traditionnelle jaquette
pour le complet veston quitte le
ministère de l'économie des finances
place du palais royal
il se rend en voiture par la rue de
rivoli et la place de la concorde à
l'angle des avenues gabriel et marie
10h15 c'est à pied que valéry giscard
d'estaing parcourt les quelques 300 m
qui le conduiront à l'entrée du palais
de l'elysée côté rue du faubourg saint
thonan 10h30 le nouveau chef de l'état
est attendu aux portes du palais
présidentiel par le premier ministre
pierre messmer au son du chant du départ
qui l'accompagné tout au long de sa
campagne électorale le président giscard
d'estaing passe en revue un détachement
de la garde républicaine avant d'être
accueilli sur le perron de la cour
d'honneur par celui qui a été président
par intérim alain poher 10h45 alors que
21 coups de canon sont tirés des jardins
des tuileries le président du conseil
constitutionnel roger frey annonce dans
l'immense salle des fêtes de l'élysée
les résultats officiels de l'élection
présidentielle c'est ensuite la remise
dans un coffret à valéry giscard
d'estaing du grand collier de la légion
d'honneur et avant de prononcer sa
première allocution officielle le
président de la république signe le
procès verbal de son installation le
cercle des personnalités présentes
demain dans la salle des fêtes sera
élargi on notera également la présence
d'une trentaine d'enfants d'une école de
courbure 11h15 valéry giscard d'estaing
gagne le perron du parc de l'elysée deux
unités du contingent du deuxième dragon
régiment dans lequel il a combattu lors
de la dernière guerre lui rendre les
honneurs
enfin 12 heures le président de la
république quitte l'elysée pour l'étoile
au carrefour georges cinq champs elysées
il abandonne à nouveau sa voiture pour
se rendre à pied est toujours au son du
chant du départ à la place charles de
gaulle
et puis c'est la traditionnelle
cérémonie sous l'arc de triomphe la
seule dont le protocole est inchangé
cérémonie qui clôturera la première
matinée officielle est très chargé du
nouveau président de la république
française
toutes ces cérémonies on vous l'a dit
seront retransmises en direct à partir
de 10h 5 sur les deux chaînes de
télévision mais le voeu du nouveau
président et que les parisiens et
parisiennes s'y associer à ces
cérémonies par leur présence et c'est
pourquoi il a décidé d'innover notamment
en arrivant à pied à l'elysée par
l'avenue marigny et en remontant
toujours à pied la partie haute des
champs elysées comme le veut la
tradition le nouveau président de la
république sera reçu demain soir à 18h30
à l'hôtel de ville de paris par le
président du conseil de paris monsieur
dominati et les membres du bureau
là encore le protocole sera simplifiée
auparavant monsieur valéry giscard
d'estaing aura rendu visite à alain
pompidou vers 17h45 à son domicile
parisien du quai de béthune c'est la
désignation d'un nouveau premier
ministre qui ouvrira le 1er chapitre
politique du cepta les choses iront très
vite à 15h30 demain pierre messmer donne
sa démission à 16h l'on collé le nom de
son successeur alors des noms étaient
lancés c'est celui de monsieur jacques
chirac
l'actuel ministre de l'intérieur qui
revient le plus souvent il semble exclu
comme on l'avait dit que ce soit un haut
fonctionnaire un technicien qui
s'installe à l'hôtel matignon
jacques chirac correspond en tout cas
aux profils de la personnalité politique
acquis valéry giscard d'estaing voudrait
confier la direction du gouvernement
profil qu'il a tracée lui même au cours
de cinq ans
le lendemain mardi à 18h soit rendue
publique la composition du nouveau
gouvernement n'est pas impossible qu'il
y ait là aussi des innovations l'on part
d'une équipe plus concentrée d'un nombre
restreint de ministres travaillant
directement avec le président de la
république sans que pour autant
d'ailleurs l'organisation actuelle de
l'administration soit totalement
bouleverse mercredi prochain 1er conseil
et après ce conseil le gouvernement sera
prêt à subir sa première épreuve son
examen de passage devant la nouvelle
majorité qui va je vous le rappelle des
réformateurs à luder se présentera-t-il
dès jeudi prochain à l'assemblée ou
attendra-t-il le mardi 4 juin la semaine
suivant dans quelles conditions les
députés ce coach se confrontent il part
donc
après avoir entendu le premier ministre
exposer son programme un programme
largement inspirée par des
préoccupations sociales économiques faut
s'attendre à des mesures précises et
rapides et bien rien n'est encore
définitivement arrêté en ce qui concerne
le calendrier mais il ya de fortes
chances pour que le nouveau gouvernement
engage son existence d'entrée de jeu
valéry giscard d'estaing l'avait laissé
entendre au cours de sa campagne
ça sera évidemment cette phase
parlementaire ce chapitre 2 qui sera le
plus passionnant à suivre la situation
politique ayant considérablement évolué
avec l'élection de valéry giscard
d'estaing des regroupements s'opéreront
au centre notamment lui dr devra définir
les conditions de sa participation à la
nouvelle majorité et l'opposition qui a
l'intention si l'on en croit monsieur
mitterrand de se manifester pleinement
mettre au point peut-être qui sait un
nouveau style mais n'anticipons pas sur
les chapitres suivants
demain donc en tout cas monsieur giscard
d'estaing sera le vingtième président de
la république française le troisième de
la vème république qui a vu les pouvoirs
présidentiels élargi par la constitution
mais rappelons justement ce soir quelles
sont les fonctions du président de la
république
les pouvoirs du président de la
quels sont ils exactement la
constitution de 1958
modifié par le référendum de 1962 qui
instituait l'élection du président des
français au suffrage universel la
constitution de 1958 donne des pouvoirs
au président de la république sans
rapport avec ce que détenaient les
présidents sous la quatrième république
par son arbitrage le président assure le
fonctionnement régulier des pouvoirs
publics ainsi que la continuité de
l'état
il est le garant de l'indépendance
nationale et de l'intégrité du
territoire et il peut mettre fin à ses
fonctions
il préside également le conseil des
ministres un et il peut prononcer la
dissolution de l'assemblée nationale
il a également le pouvoir de soumettre
au référendum tout projet de loi portant
sur l'organisation des pouvoirs publics
ou sur la ratification d'un traité qui
pourrait avoir des incidences sur le
fonctionnement des institutions comme
ses prédécesseurs monsieur valéry
giscard d'estaing signera les
ordonnances et les décrets délibéré en
conseil des ministres est commun il
nommera les conseillers d'état
le grand chancelier de la légion
d'honneur les préfets les recteurs
d'académie
les conseillers maîtres de la cour des
comptes comme eux encore il accréditera
les ambassadeurs français auprès des
puissances étrangères tandis que les
ambassadeurs de ces mêmes puissances
seront accrédités auprès de lui l'armée
à présent et bien le président de la
république et le chef de toutes les
armées et en tant que tel il préside les
conseils et les qualités supérieures de
la défense nationale et puis lorsque les
institutions de la république sont
menacés bon ce soir
quelles sont les fonctions du président
de la république
les pouvoirs du président de la
république
quels sont ils exactement la
constitution de 1958
modifié par le référendum de 1962 qui
instituait l'élection du président des
français au suffrage universel la
constitution de 1958 donne des pouvoirs
au président de la république sans
rapport avec ce que des tonnelles et
président sous la quatrième république
par son arbitrage le président assure le
fonctionnement régulier des pouvoirs
publics ainsi que la continuité de
l'état
il est le garant de l'indépendance
nationale et de l'intégrité du
territoire
et il peut mettre fin à ses fonctions
il préside également le conseil des
ministres et il peut prononcer la
dissolution de l'assemblée nationale
il a également le pouvoir de soumettre
au référendum tout projet de loi portant
sur l'organisation des pouvoirs publics
ou sur la ratification d'un traité qui
pourrait avoir des incidences sur le
fonctionnement des institutions comme
ses prédécesseurs monsieur valéry
giscard d'estaing signera les
ordonnances et les décrets délibéré en
conseil des ministres est commun il
nommera les conseillers d'état
le grand chancelier de la légion
d'honneur
les préfets les recteurs d'académie les
conseillers maîtres de la cour des
comptes comme eux encore il accréditera
les ambassadeurs français auprès des
puissances étrangères tandis que les
ambassadeurs de ces mêmes puissances
seront accrédités auprès de lui l'armée
à présent et bien le président de la
république et le chef de toutes les
armées et en tant que tel il préside les
conseils et les comités supérieur de la
défense nationale et puis lorsque les
institutions de la république sont
menacées d'une manière grave lorsque
sont menacés également l'indépendance de
la nation l'intégrité du territoire
le président peut appliquer l'article 16
de la constitution et prendre ainsi
toutes les mesures exigées par les
circonstances
il en va de même lorsque le
fonctionnement régulier des pouvoirs
publics constitutionnels se trouve
interrompue
en plus il est le garant de
l'indépendance de l'autorité judiciaire
et il préside le conseil supérieur de la
magistrature qui l'assistent dans cette
fonction
tels sont tous contenus dans la
constitution les principes au pouvoir de
monsieur valéry giscard d'estaing 20e
président de la république française
à genève on attend toujours tout est
prêt pour la signature de l'accord sur
le désengagement militaire entre israël
et la syrie
il pourrait être annoncée d'un instant à
l'autre simultanément à damas et à
jérusalem monsieur kissinger a fait
aujourd'hui la navette entre le bureau
de madame golda meir et celui du
président syrien entre jérusalem et
damas afin de s'efforcer de régler les
derniers détails les désaccords qui
portait semble-t-il essentiellement sur
les contingents des forces des nations
unies et l'importance des zones de
sécurité de part et d'autre des
frontières dont jérusalem l'accord
semble acquis bien que tous les membres
du gouvernement ne se soient pas montrés
favorables au plan kissinger
mais madame golda meir à porter
elle-même un toast au secrétaire d'état
américain pour at elle dit la
compréhension et la patience dont il a
fait preuve sur le terrain
malheureusement encore des incidents
aujourd'hui des avions syriens ont
bombardé des positions israéliennes dans
le golan tandis que les combats
terrestres se poursuivait sur le mont
hermon un tout autre aspect de
l'actualité internationale chez l'un de
nos voisins le plus petit des 9 du
marché commun ont voté aujourd'hui
luxembourg seul le grand duc jean ne
vote pas il est citoyen à part entière
mais il n'est pas dans les usages qu'ils
prennent part aux luttes politiques du
pays en revanche vote obligatoire pour
les deux cent mille électeurs du grand
duché qui ont eu à renouveler leur
parlement 59 députés
et puis de cette élection sortira un
nouveau gouvernement sept ministres et
deux secrétaires d'état
au luxembourg on vote parce qu'il
convient de respecter la démocratie car
l'élan politique l'intérêt pour une
campagne électorale tout cela ne
caractérise pas particulièrement
l'esprit luxembourgeois on se passionne
davantage pour ce qui se passe chez les
voisins
chez les français en particulier alors
qu'elle pronostiquait bien n'apparaît
pas bien difficile certainement les
sociaux chrétiens vont l'emporter une
fois de plus et leur leader monsieur
werner formera une fois de plus le
nouveau gouvernement après tout cela ne
fait que quinze ans qu'il est à la tête
de l'état alors pourquoi changer tout va
si bien au luxembourg même le seul
problème
l'inflation est un problème qui n'est
pas d'origine luxembourgeoise
c'est de l'inflation à porter car les
trois quarts de ceux qui se vendent
s'achètent et se consomme à l'intérieur
du grand duché provient de l'extérieur
c'est donc l'inflation des autres qui
est venu troubler la vie paisible de ce
petit pays dont la population n'est même
pas égale à celle d'un département
français moyen plus petit mais 100 fois
plus riches les banques les sièges
sociaux ils sont les industries les plus
florissantes
voilà pourquoi le petit luxembourg
demeure un partenaire intéressant dans
la communauté européenne des neuf et il
tient à y jouer son rôle il dispute
d'ailleurs âprement à strasbourg et à
bruxelles l'honneur d'être le siège des
institutions européennes et il fait tout
pour cela
en attendant élections et vie politique
n'auront été qu'une occupation d'un
dimanche matin
il n'y avait jusqu'à présent
pratiquement aucun espoir de permettre
un jour à ceux qui naissent sourd de
naissance de pouvoir entendre
certes le miracle ne s'est pas produit
mais les spécialistes français sont
parvenus à donner une certaine capacité
d'audition à des sujets condamné à une
surdité totale
c'est une grande première que pierre
boucher va nous expliquer grâce aux
images exceptionnelles que l'équipe de
médecins spécialistes a bien voulu nous
permettre de filmer depuis quand vous
êtes sourde et c'est venu comme un jour
depuis plus de trente ans cette femme
entend à nouveau
tel est l'un des résultats
extraordinaires présenté au récent
congrès mondial d'audiologie par une
équipe de spécialistes français dirigé
par le professeur pialoux principe de la
technique des sélecteurs de fréquences
alimentée par de simples piles achemine
par des fils des impulsions sonores
jusqu'à l'oreille interne de la malade
qui a été spécialement appareiller
cette maquette d'une réu men a grandi
nous permet de comprendre l'opération
passant à travers l'os temporal des
électrodes sont implantés dans la
cochlée que voici
ce sont ces électrodes qui reliés par
des fils aux appareils que nous avons vu
transmettent les sons au cerveau par
l'intermédiaire du nerf auditif que vous
voyez ici pour la première fois au monde
des phases de cette intervention était
filmé ici la fraise du chirurgien
prépare l'endroit où sera implantée la
première électrodes
nous sommes à quelques millimètres du
cerveau le chirurgien opère certes sous
microscope
mais il peut à tout instant surveillez
très agrandie l'image télévisée de son
champ opératoire
les électrodes destiné aux patients sont
alors préparé jusqu'à présent son sol
justiciables de cette opération les
sourds totaux in appareil à bhl est
certes un sourd muet de naissance et
voici l'instant le plus délicat la pose
de l'électrode sur la cochlée toutes ces
électrodes seront collées à l'aide d'un
produit spécial voici une électrode en
place le volet osseux et ensuite replacé
sur le crâne il se résoudre à tout seul
en quelques mois
l'opération est maintenant terminée mais
quels sont les résultats obtenus grâce à
cette technique et surtout même très
encourageants puisque ces sujets
obtiennent une heure reconnaissance de
la parole qui leur permet d'avoir une
vie sociale presque normal ils ont même
d'ailleurs une reconnaissance musicale
dr simple et qui est particulièrement
remarquée appartement excellente
cependant il faut souligner le fait que
d'abord nous manquons de recul dans le
temps puisque nous avons à peine un an
et puis également nous avons trop peu de
malades pour pouvoir affirmer que la
qualité de ces résultats sera toujours
la même pour tout le monde
nous avons encore deux difficultés
principal à surmonter la première un
matériel
et puis il ya surtout un problème
technique qui est essentiellement la
miniaturisation de l'ensemble de
l'appareil âge qui vous a vu assez gros
et assez volumineux il faut qu'on arrive
à faire un petit appareil qui soit
finalement pas plus gros qu'une boîte
d'allumettes de ménage qui puisse être
porté en permanence sur le haut niveau
du goût sel dans la poche
il sera relié justin fille au voisinage
de l'oreille et qui permettra ainsi à
ces sourds d'entendre normalement
correctement sans l'aide d'un
appareillage absolument extraordinaire
donc c'est un fait n'y ait ni un palier
alliés
madame
nous avons les jours précédents
présenter une enquête sur les remous
politiques qui agitent actuellement les
états unis la sphère watergate n'est
toujours pas terminée et on ignore
quelles pourront être ses conséquences
pour le président nixon
sera-t-il ou non destitué en tout cas
envers et contre tous les chars nixon
n'a pas l'intention de démissionner et
il reste impassible poursuivant toutes
ses activités habituelles
c'est cet aspect de ses rapports avec
l'opinion publique que denis poncet va
nous montrer ce soir alors que l'on
attend de savoir si le président nixon
sera ou non contraints par la cour
suprême de remettre les bandes
magnétiques qu'il détient encore
soumission des conversations
présidentielle enregistré à la
commission judiciaire de la chambre des
représentants par le président richard
nixon le 30 avril 1974 en publiant cet
ouvrage de 13 cents huit pages
le président a ainsi refusé de céder aux
injonctions la commission judiciaire et
du jus syrie cas à remettre les bandes
magnétiques ouvrage temps dans ce format
qu'en livre de poche connaît un succès
énorme
une aubaine pour les éditeurs car il
n'en a versé aucun droit d'auteur dans
l'introduction
les avocats en s'appuyant sur des
extraits affirment-ils un sens du
président mais le public a réagi
autrement pour eux le livre est
accablant mais le président ne semblent
pas prêter attention à ces réactions et
continue sa campagne de charme à travers
les états unis
faute de pouvoir vraiment diriger le
pays
voilà ainsi le président nixon arrivant
à l'aéroport militaire de phoenix mais
cela pourrait être l'oklahoma le texas
miami le scénario est toujours le même
tout au long de la route qui mène à la
réunion les manifestants sont là nixon
les ignore ce soir là au stade de
phoenix ils sont quinze mille
républicain convaincu à attendre nixon
les organisateurs ont lancé des
invitations payant puis se ravisant ont
laissé les portes ouvertes où seuls
membres du par le maître de cérémonie et
barry goldwater sénateur de l'arizona et
candidat malheureux en 64 la présidence
des états unis puis à lons et l entrée
sur le terrain d'une équipe de football
c'est l'arrivée du président et de
madame richard nixon
l'arizona est inquiète républicain
depuis très longtemps on affirme même
que phoenix est la ville la plus
conservatrice des états unis echard
nixon d'ailleurs a passé une partie de
sa jeunesse dans cette ville
c'est donc en quelque sorte un enfant du
pays
pour présenter le président le chef du
parti républicain à la chambre des
représentants john roll
il déclare c'est un grand privilège pour
moi de vous présenter un grand président
il est à noter qu'à peine 24 heures plus
tard ce même john rhodes demandé pour le
bien des états unis la démission du
président mais en tout cas dans le
désert de l'arizona ce soir les
républicains semblent ne jamais avoir
été aussi unis sous la bannière du roi
richard
avec
enfin c'est le moment du discours même
avec la veille et a23 près que celui du
land avec surtout ces trois phrases
la première le moment est venu du billet
wachovia était de continuer les affaires
de l'état
la deuxième a trait aux américains qui
sont contre lui et aux rares
manifestants qui ont réussi à rentrer
laissez moi dire que dans la grande
tradition américaine il y a quelques uns
ce soir qui s'en contre nous béziers l'a
beaucoup plus qu'ils sont avec nous
enfin le final depuis six mois c'est
toujours le même
et ce soir je peux vous affirmer que je
compte rester à mon poste et avec votre
aide nous y parviendrons
le discours a duré 15 minutes
le président se retire presque aussitôt
et regagne l'aéroport at il convaincu
mais qu'y avait-il à convainc là ça ne
lui était elle pas déjà acquise
presque derrière ses applaudissements
aussi fourni soit il le doute n'est pas
absent et de ces réunions qui ont les
lure de films à grand spectacle les
spectateurs se demandent avec angoisse
si l'acteur est toujours à la hauteur de
son rôle les sondages
ouf aujourd'hui que 75% des américains
désavoue le président
nous avons reçu pendant ce journal les
rapports du tiercé l'arrivée je vous le
rappelle 4,17 et un le rapport pour
trois francs dans l'ordre 4908 francs et
dans le désordre toujours pour trois
francs 981 francs 60 comme vous le voyez
en ce moment sur votre écran nous
n'avons pas oublier bien entendu c'est
aujourd'hui la fête des mères et nous
n'allons tout de même pas nous séparer
sans l'évoquer la fête des mères c'est
aussi une fête pour tous les enfants qui
ont cherché le cadeau et surtout
l'intention qui pouvait faire le plus
plaisir
ces images de promenade dans un jardin
public ne représente pas bien sûr tout
ce qu'est la mer ni l'étendue de sa
tâche
mais un moment important où elle est
proche de son enfant observe ces
réactions devant la nature le jeu les
autres enfants toute cette partie du
monde extérieur dans lequel il faudra
bien un jour le lâcher à toutes les
mères de famille sont près de 15
millions en france
nous souhaitons bien sûr beaucoup de
bonheur je vous retrouverai ce soir vers
22h20 pour 24 heures dernière bonsoir